hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt heute geht es was leckeres was
gesundes ich mache nämlich einen spinat
salat mit gebackenem schafskäse also der
spinat salat alleine ist natürlich sehr
gesund da gebackene schafskäse ist noch
mal so ein extra zusatz von mir und ich
mache das ganz gerne auch mal abends
weil da hat man wenig kohlenhydrate bzw
gar keine wenn man den schafskäse mit
der panade weglässt und ich zeige euch
jetzt einfach mal kurz die zutaten mehr
spaß ist hier natürlich nicht alle
zutaten also das ist eigentlich nur
monats zutaten weil er ja mit sense
produkt weil er nämlich keiner
stoffwechsel diät macht ja sie zac des
monats tut dann déi verzehrt wurde es an
verstand sich kein pferd ist noch nicht
alles für ihn ist natürlich für uns für
die ganze woche zu der wocheneinkauf an
obst und gemüse aber ich jetzt zeige ich
euch einfach mal die zutaten
ich habe hier etwas spinat isst 200
gramm blattspinat und zwar so ein junger
spieler wie spinat
dann habe ich hier ein paar wahl müsse
und eine birne und für das dressing
brauche ich etwas balsamico essig
orangensaft olivenöl und eine
knoblauchzehe und natürlich auch salz
und pfeffer und für den schafskäse
brauche ich hier eben schafskäse
da habe ich jetzt hier diesen schafskäse
genommen das ist eine ganz kleine dose
finde ich ganz praktisch weil da einfach
zwei mädchen drin sind und dann noch ein
ei da brauche ich dann auch gleich
pfeffer und hier noch so ein bisschen
paniermehl ich fange jetzt einfach
direkt schon mal mit dem schafskäse an
und panierten jetzt schon mal dafür
halte ich ihn jetzt hier einmal
einmal so dass ich eben vier scheiben ab
und das ist dann auch so ein salat
erreicht entweder wenn man so bittel als
hauptspeise nimmt zu für zwei personen
oder eben für vier bis fünf personen
wenn man einfach das als beilage hat
dabei vier personen finde ich perfekt
weil man hat ja auch dann hier so käser
stücke es gebe ich mein einfach in so
einem großen teller und wird es mit
pfeffer salz kommt nicht rein valletta
schafskäse schon salzig genug ist aber
so bisschen pfeffer chili kommt auch mit
rein und das werdet einfach kurz
verrührt mit einem kleinen schneebesen
oder mit einer gabel
und es mache ich es einfach so ich nehme
jetzt sind die eine hand den schafskäse
und wendet ist drin kann man auch mit
einer zange machen
dann gebe ich es rüber zu familien und
schüttelt ist einfach so bis jetzt
könnte das entweder zu lassen oder
einfach nochmal panieren also mache ich
es gerne hat man nämlich eine dickere
kruste also doppelt paniert
und dann kann ich das hier einfach
ablegen und die restlichen auch parieren
den schafskäse kann ich jetzt einfach
mal kurz zur seite stellen
ich werde nämlich zuerst die marina für
den salat vorbereiten
und es ist eben auch etwas ist aber
vorbereiten in den kühlschrank stellen
und einfach am mittag oder am abend dann
auspacken
ich nehme jetzt für die marinade einfach
so eine von einer dose zum pressing und
brauche jetzt balsamico-essig davon
nämlich zwei esslöffel
drei esslöffel olivenöl
rund 3 esslöffel vom orangensaft ich
habe jetzt ein aus der flasche aber
können zum beispiel auch einfach selber
welchem zustand so ein richtig schönes
fruchtiges dressing und da gebe ich
jetzt einen halben teelöffel senf mit
dazu
schauen dressing was man für andere
salate gut benutzen kann einfach so
schön ja fruchtig säuerlich jetzt noch
mit pfeffer abschmecken
und ich gebe da jetzt noch knoblauch mit
rein allerdings möchte ich jetzt halt
netz dass er mehr so arg nach knoblauch
stinken
jetzt habe ich zu abgedrückt deswegen
halte ich den knoblauch einfach ging
jetzt so ganz gut und steckt es einfach
mich hier rein und hab es aber dann
später nicht im salat mit drin sondern
einfach nur so wissen das aroma jetzt
kann ich den deckel verschließen und
muss man noch kräftig schütteln
so sieht jetzt es fertige dressing aus
sie zwar jetzt vielleicht so appetitlich
aus aber schmeckt wirklich sehr gut
jetzt nehme ich noch die birne die
könnte entweder mit schale lassen
ich nehme sie jetzt hier runter weil
hier die schale so ein bisschen hart ist
aber ansonsten habe ich es eigentlich
ganz gern wenn das gemüse unterschätzt
oder ist optisch zum geschehen lässt
deswegen stehe ich das jetzt hier ganz
kurz das mache ich jetzt zum schluss
damit sonne zu frauen wird und kann sie
dann hier oben den stil ab und halbieren
danach wird sie geschüttelt und jetzt
kann ich auch das innere rausnehmen und
einfach nochmal halbieren oder dritteln
da habe ich bis kleinere stücke so und
die geht jetzt hier vorne schon mal mit
in meinen teller rhein-main schälchen
besser gesagt
das ist wieder so ein rezept wo man
denkt es passt vielleicht gar nicht was
total gut also der murat mag das ja
eigentlich nicht so wenn man obst mit
dem normale salat hat entweder wieder
obstsalat oder wieder normale salat mit
gemüse ja so wie es beim normalen
menschen auch ist genau aber es ist halt
so bei dem rezept finde ich dass die
birne echt ganz gut kommt weil das so
dieses fruchtige mit rein bringt gerade
so zum schafskäse fasst es hat richtig
gut
wir haben auch noch etwas mit creme
brulée gelesen oder was war das case in
nigeria wäre epallé mit käse also das
war ein bissel java fähige folgendes war
wird nicht mehr als käse mit zucker
praktisch ja man nicht so ganz meins
aber es war irgendwie auch leckeren ob
ich würde glaube ich nicht selber
nachmachen
ich gebe jetzt hier mein dressing drüber
damit die bären jetzt hat auch nicht so
braun werden und jetzt vermisse ich das
einfach mit meinen salatbesteck so
werden die blätter braun die denen man
vorher weiß wieso sehen die besucher
getrunken
der jetzt in sich die soße aber ich
meine damit dass eben meister wird beim
apfel hat das ist nicht so oxidiert
jetzt gebe ich hier noch mal kurz rein
denn ich will jetzt kurz meinen spinat
gleichheit von an machen aber schaltet
jetzt erstmal eine pfanne an
dies soll jetzt erst mal heiß werden
denn es mir jetzt alles gleichzeitig
fertig muss jetzt im prinzip nur noch
den schafskäse auspacken und gebe dafür
ja so etwa vier fünf sechs esslöffel
olivenöl in einer pfanne und lasst es
hier heiß werden und sobald das fett an
heiß ist gebe ich den schafskäse rein
der aussage nehmen sie 34 56 es kommt ja
darauf an wie groß die pfanne erstattete
boden sollte halt gut bedeckt sein damit
es eben nicht dran klebt damit auch
schön knusprig wird deswegen vier bis
sechs wochen kann auch weniger sein mit
ihren kleinen ab wann habt jetzt lassen
wir es einfach von allen seiten so schön
goldbraun anbraten
am besten bei mittlerer bis mittel hoher
hitze also nicht zu heiss damit der
schafskäse ihnen eben auch die
möglichkeit hat das eher warm wird weil
wenn außen die großstadt durch die
schonende schafskäse noch kalt ist
schmeckt eben letzter gut wie wenn der
käse auch schön war mit etwa fünf bis
sechs minuten
und ich mache hier in der zwischenzeit
kurz sauber und mag es einfach und kann
einfach den salat gleich anrichten und
dann immer schon fertig ich glaube dass
es ein blitz rezept ich habe jetzt
vielleicht zehn minuten gebraucht nur
schmeckt richtig lecker lecker
so jetzt sind die hessische schaafs
riesige fakten und jetzt habe ich ihn
heraus geholt damit er so ein bisschen
noch abtropfen kann also das fed so ein
bisschen auf der kirchentreppe
küchenkrepp bleibt und jetzt nehme ich
mir meinen spinat und kann den
marinieren
ich habe jetzt hier bereits die
knoblauchzehen rausgeholt damit ich dir
einfach nicht im salat mit drin hab und
geht jetzt ihr den spinat rein
ich nehme jetzt alles gespielt als
musikerin und verrührt es jetzt einfach
so ein bisschen mit den locken
und jetzt ist das gericht auch schon
fertig also das ist wirklich ein ganz
ganz schnelles rezept man wird salate
sind eigentlich ganz schnell
dies ist ein baby spinat ja trotzdem
essen was ist ein süßes baby stillen
normalen spieler deshalb feiner und die
blätter werden eben gezupft wenn er noch
kleiner ist und der andere chance zu
grob und dem ist man erst klein machen
und den lasse ich einfach ganz also ich
finde es halt viel schöner ja nicht dass
ich auf die idee kommen die armen babys
oder so was also
gibts ja alles ich will dich daran
erinnern was sie gesagt was gesagt
modells zumal am 8 ich serviere das
jetzt hier auf einem großen teller sieht
auch richtig hübsch aus und der morath
kriegt gleich sein probiert eller soll
ich will kein probierte ich möchte
richtig ist ich hab sogar das große
sterben
das große ist fürs foto deswegen
jetzt nehme ich die walnüsse und
zerteilt die so grob darüber und die
sagen halt für den richtigen krampf also
schön knackig bienen kinder jetzt auch
cool oder erdnüsse erdnüsse ich meine
wenn man muss allergie hat nimmt man
halt kiening kenne oder mandeln oder was
anderes und jetzt gebe ich noch die
bienenstöcke mit drauf die könnte halt
echt schön dekorativ so wissen wir schon
gegessen also wenn ich jetzt kein profi
tyler gebraucht aber ich finde aber man
wundert sich wie gut ist ein schmecken
mit der bühne manchmal immerhin wie kann
man so was essen und dann ist monster
und denken immer noch wie kann man das
essen schmeckt irgendwie passt also das
volk stecke ich finde aber auch dass
auch asche gut passen wird er halt
wieder was ganz anderes
und dann gebe ich den schafskäse einfach
oben drauf ich komme nicht überraschend
dass ich bin überrascht was ich finde es
wirklich klasse keiner drauf was ich hab
mir mal was anderes
du freust dich bestimmt schon auf deinen
teller so hunger sally ich gebe noch ein
bisserl dressing drücken
aber es schneit es jetzt einfach mal auf
damit ihr sehen wie die kompetenz von
dem ist als außenrum richtig knusprig
und innen dann dieser weiche käse der
anfängt so ein bisschen zu verlaufen
aber nicht zu sehr also der schutz nicht
weich und läuft raus sondern hat noch
ein bisschen bis ist schön warm und dem
uranbedarf das probieren
muss man eigentlich immer so alles
zusammen und nimmer oder nacheinander
halbzeit ressing und die ganze schädlich
ganz ehrlich das weiß im prinzip mein
rezept für den spinat salat mit dem
gebackenen schafskäse
wer zum beispiel jetzt eine
glutenunverträglichkeit hart und jetzt
den schafskäse nicht parieren kann kann
das ganze auch zum beispiel weil spanier
besteht aus weizenmehl also aus
weizenbrot könnte zum beispiel auch
irgendeine andere mail sorte verwenden
die ihr vertrag
also das ist komplett egal ihr könnt
auch nur mehl benutzen als jetzt für
alle anderen die kein paniermehl haben
und es trotzdem machen wollen das ist
wirklich was man könnte auch trauben
nehmen statt birnen also da könnt ihr
wieder einfach so eurem geschmack
entsprechend bis abwandeln und könnte
mir ein bild auf facebook oder instagram
schicken und wir lassen uns ist jetzt
noch schmecken und wir sehen uns dann
beim nächsten mal wieder
bis bald man kann auch fleisch salat